اهلا بكم من جديد في العراق تحولت الذكرى
السنويه الثالثه لاغتيال الجنرال الايراني
قاسم سليماني مسؤول العمليات الخارجيه في
الحرس الثوري ونائب رئيس هيئه الحشد
الشعبي ابو مهدي المهندس تحولت الى مناسبه
انقسام حاد بين احزاب الاطار التنسيقيه
الشيعي نتيجه تامه تم تداوله عن انها
حكومه محمد شيعه السوداني وافقت على طلب
امريكي بمنع مسيره تابين مليونيه لسليمان
في العراق ومرت الذكرى بانشطه محدوده حيث
تم تعطيل الدوام الرسمي في اغلب المحافظات
العراقيه باستثناء اقليم كردستان العراق
كما كانت هناك تجمعات المهرجانيه في
العديد من المحافظات مع تجمع المئات في
مكان مقتل المهندس وسليماني داخل مطار
بغداد اما باقي شوارع العاصمه بغداد
فشاهده حركه طبيعيه
[موسيقى]
نناقش الموضوع من عمان مع رعد هاشم البحث
في الشهر العراقي ومن بغداد واثق الجابري
الباحث السياسي مرحبا بكما ضيفيا الكريمين
استاذ رعد هاشم لماذا تم الغاءه مليونيه
قاسم سليمان في بغداد
يعني اختلفت الاراء حول هذا الموضوع ولكن
هي تتفق على عدم استفزاز الامريكان بل
هناك من يشير لانه السفاره الامريكيه او
السفيره طلبت منه السيد السوداني لا يشجع
على اقامه مثل هكذا تجمعات او حتى مسيرات
كان هناك كلام عن السيارات او حتى
استعراضات عسكريه ولكن همم خشيه من
استفزاز الجانب الامريكي وربما تصل للجموع
في احتجاجاتها
الى السفاره ربما يحصل يحصل استفزازات
اخرى هذا
التطور ربما يشير الى تباين في الموقف
موقف الجماعات المسلحه موقف الاطار الذي
بعضه قسم الى مؤيد لهذه السياسه اي عدم
استفزاز الامريكان ومن هم يشير الى وجود
محور جديد باتحاد
محور المقاومه اتحاد محور المقاومه هذا
جديد بعيدا عن تنسيقيه المقاومه التي
اعتقدناها نجدها هذا الاتحاد الجديد قد
استغنى عن همم
جماعه العصائر
فقط بهذا الاتحاد الجديد لجماعات لكتائب
حزب الله وانه جاء طيب جماعه المالك طيب
واثق الجابري في بغداد هل حقا الحكومه
العراقيه لا تريد استفزاز الامريكيين
باقامه مليونيه
قاسم سليماني قد تتطور الى مشاهد امام
السفاره الامريكيه ام همم ربما هناك
انقسام حاد كذلك بين الاطار التنسيقي نفسه
نعم شكرا جزيلا لكم تحيه لكم مشاهديكم
الكرام ولل الضيف الكريم بطبيعه الحال
طبعا
التظاهر المليونيه لم تلغى وانما تحول
التجمع الى التجمع في مكان الحادث في شارع
المطار
اقيم في تلك الليله يعني مناسبه يعني او
تجمع بدا من السادسه مساء الى الواحد
بعدها منتصف الليل ويتجمع فيه الملايين
وحضر فيه همم كثير من القاده السياسيه
طبيعه الحال لماذا
التجمع الى هذا المكان يعني
همم تظاهرات مليونيه هي حدثت يعني خلال
هذه الايام عده فعاليات بدات منذ قبله
ثلاثه ايام من الحادث في اماكن متعدده من
العراق
والى اليوم هي مستمره كذلك همم هي همم
صادفت يعني مع عيال راس السنه الميلاديه
وكذلك استعدادات العراق همم بطوله خليجي
لذلك انشغالات العراق ربما حتى شعب العراق
معظمهم ومنشغل بهذه المناسبات بالاضافه
الى طبيعه تقلبات الظروف الجويه التي دعت
حتى الحكومه العراقيه لا تعطيل الدوام
الرسمي يوم غد كل هذه العوامل هي ربما ادت
الى جعل الفعاليات يافعاليات متعدده في
معظم محافظات العراق باضافه الى تعطيل
الدوام الرسمي في تلك المحافظات وايضا همم
مكان التجمع اضافه الى طبيعه الظروف
الامنيه والسياسيه الغير مستقره في العراق
يعني وجود مثل هكذا تجمعات في الوقت
الراهن يعني تتعلق الامور بامور اجرائيه
ام هناك من يرى الحقيقه همم استاذ واثق
انه ربما كذلك همم انه همم هناك همم دعنا
نقول همم فقدان للحماس فيما يتعلق همم
احياء ذكرى همم مقتل سليمان بالنظر على
انه الرد او الانتقام الذي كان ي الحرس
الثوري وايران لم يحصل الى غايه الان يعني
في الذكرى الثالثه لم لم يكن هناك همم
تحقيق لهذا الانتقام الذي وعدوا به
نعم نحن نتحدث عن الواقع العراقي الواقع
العراقي يعني هو الطلب العراقي ربما هو
يجمع عليه كل القاده بما فيهم ما صرح به
رئيس الوزراء بتحقيق السياده الكامله
للعراق والسياده العراق الكامله يعني عدم
وجود قوات اجنبيه في داخل البلد يعني تحت
اي ظروف والعراق يبسط يعني يستطيع بسط
الامن النظام بنفسه دون الاستعانه باي
قوات خارجيه لذلك يعني كل الفعاليات التي
او كل القوى السياسيه عبرت بشكل واضح وهي
ادانت الحادثه مره اخرى وعبرت براي الشجب
والاستكار باللهجه عاليه يعني كانت كل
الحديث لم يوجد احد لم يعبر عن رايه هو او
لم يودين الحدث الان سواء بالاوساط
السياسيه او حتى في الاوساط الشعبيه طيب
استاذ رائد ما رايك في مقاله الاستاذ واثق
انه صحيح الهمم يعني المليونيه لم تلغى
ولكن تحولات الى نشاطات يعني همم اصغر
بسبب امور اخرى متعلقه بالامن وبالطقس
وبالشغال العراقيين
لا هم ما يهمهم لمن يريدوا يطلعوا
انتظاهرات ما يهمم لا تق- السؤال لا مطر
لانه كثير من الناس الولائيه تحتفي بهذا
الموضوع او يعني تستذكره ولا يهمها موضوع
المطر لا هناك اتفاقات حقيقه
واضحه لعدم استفزاز بجانب الامريكي ولا بل
حتى هناك اضافات انه يعني يريدون ان يملوا
على السيد السوداني انه اذا ذهب الى
الولايات المتحده يعطوه فرصه يعني ولكن
بالمقابل
طيب
لماذا استجابت حكومه همم محمد شياع
السوداني للطلب الامريكي هذه المره في
مقابل ماذا همم برايك
يعني هناك
اتفاق على التهدئه يبدو حتى انه لا يحصل
ازمه امنيه وحتى لا يستفز الوضع اكثر
ويصار الى تصعيد يعني اكثر من هذا الذي
مرت
هكذا تجمعات وتظاهرات لا حب بلا بل حتى
السيد السوداني طلب من خامنه في زياره
ايران زياده الى ايران الا انه لا يقصفون
لا يقصفون كردستان ان لا يستفزون
الامريكان في بلده وهو ربما كان يعرف انه
لديه السفره الى الولايات المتحده لكي
يرتب الاوضاع ربما يهدئ الموقف بعض شيء
لكن هناك كما قلنا الجماعات المسلحه هي
منقسم على نفسها بين من يؤيد السوداني
ليحافظ على مكاسب ومغانم ههه بقاء الحكومه
هو استمرار هو واستمرار مغانبه ومكاسبهم
بهذا الامر سياسيا وربما حتى ماليا
والميزانيه قادمه
قريبا وايضا في المعسكر الاخر من يريد ان
يصعد مع الامريكان لفرض شروط يعني في ضمن
منهج التوصيه او التوجيه الايراني في فرض
حاله الوجود لتلك الميليشيات والجماعات
على الارض العراقيه طيب استاذ واثق
الجابري كما قال الاستاذ رعد يبدو انه
هناك رغبه في التهدئه هذه المرحله ولكن
هناك من يرى انه ربما الحكومه العراقيه
استغلت همم الوضع الداخلي في ايران الان
همم ايران منشغله قليلا بهمم بالاحتجاجات
الحاصله في الداخل همم وبالتالي هذا اثر
على حجم نفوذها في العراق وبالتالي همم
حكومه السودان استغلت هذه اللحظه في سبيل
ان تحصل على مكاسب قادمه للعراق ما رايك
في في هذا التحليل
يعني اولا لم تكن هنالك دعوه للتظاهرات
يعني
كل مره يعني او لم يوجد تحشيد يعني ولم
يوجد اعلان لوجود تظاهره او تجمع يعني في
ساحه التظاهر يعني في العام الماضي كانت
في ساحه التحرير تظاهره في هذا العام لم
يكن هنالك اي دعوه او اي تعشد ذلك لم لا
يوجد تظاهره حتى تلغى يعني بالاساس وانما
طلب التجمع في همم في شارع المطار يعني
حتى في ليلتها يعني كما تعرفون شارع
المطار هو شارع حيوي واستراتيجي همم حتى
التظاهرات هي لم ااه
لم تتعرض الى الشارع يعني ابتعدت عن شارع
وتركت حركه السير بشكل طبيعي قضيه تتعلق
بالشان الداخلي نعم العراق هو يسعى ان
يكون مستقرا بلد متوازنا يبني علاقات
متوازنه سواء على المستوى الاقليمي
والمستوى الدولي يعني نعم القضيه مال
العراق يرى ان ال- ال- قضيه هي قد تاخذ
الجانب التحقيق القضائي افضل من
التصعيد والتهديد والوعيد بهذه الطريقه
لكن مع ذلك
في داخل همم الضيف العراقي وداخل الرؤيه
السياسيه العراقيه سواء كانت من من فصائل
المقاومه او من القوى السياسيه الاخرى هي
ترى ال- ال- القضيه فيها تحقيقات
والتحقيقات متعمقه وهذه تحقيقات هي ليست
همم تخص الشيء الامريكي فقط وانما حتى تخص
شان عراقي في بعض الذين يروهم تعاونوا
بهذه القضيه على ذكر هذه الفصائل همم
اسالك يا استاذ رعد في عمان
الناشطون المقربون من الفصائل المسلحه
يعني هم غاضبون من قرار الحكومه الغاء همم
يعني هذه المليونيه الضخمه همم
لذكرى مقتل قاسم سليمان في غار همم في
بغداد برايك كيف يؤثر كذلك هذا الموقف
على جمهور الاطار التنسيقي كذلك
الميليشيات المسلحه كذلك
يعني اولا زميلي اللي تحدث عن موضوع انه
ما كانت دعوه لا كانت هناك دعوه
للتظاهر حتى الدعوه للاستعراض العسكري
بالمناسبه يعني انا اعرف هذا الشيء
بمناسبه بالنسبه لهم لكن
ايه يعني الاثبات الوجود ويعني وموضوع
ربما يتعلق بتحشيد ايراني لهذه المساله غض
النظر عن كثير من الملفات التي تعيق
الازمات الداخليه في ايران لكن فعلا حصل
الاتفاق ربما كانت بفارق اصوات معينه انه
نسمح بهذا الاستعراض لا نسمح نربط هذا
الموضوع بعد عدم همم اقامه استعراض الجيش
العراقي الذي اعتدنا عليه في كل مناسبه
سته كانون حتى هذا ايضا يعني الغي او تاجل
والعذر كان طبعا بسبب بطوله الخليج رغم
انه الاستعراض التجري في بغداد ومن صباح
الباكر وليس لها علاقه في البصره وبعيد
المسافه يعني يقال على على شان حضور السيد
رئيس الوزراء للاحتاليه هو قادر على ان
يحضر في همم في يوم واحد عشر فعاليات
الرجل يعني ايضا
متمرس حتى عيد الجيش
قال لي يوم سته كانون ليس هناك استعراض
عسكري اذا هم متفقون على ان يهدئوا الوضع
لا انت عندك استعراض ولا انا عندي استعراض
لا الدوله جماعه الدوله ولا جمعت الا
الدوله ف القضيه فيها يعني نعم فيها قضيه
القبول العراقي للطلب الامريكي على حساب
مناسبه كهذه بالنسبه للايرانيين
مو السوداني عنده زياره للولايات المتحده
كما يقولون وليس من مكتب للمكتب لم يعلن
الى الان لذلك يريدون ان يعني يروا يجس
النبض الاميركي لشخصيه السوداني وما دام
ميله لهذا الطرف او ذاك او توازنه لذلك هم
يتغيثون وهما حقيقه متوحلين موضوع
التظاهرات ذلك حتى قراني نقضاني يعني
تعبان ما يقدر كثير من هذه القضايا
ومخليها على الاتفاقات الداخليه في شان
العراق فيما بينهم القادسيه يتفقوا على
حصيله وهم اغلب الاحيان يكونوا الموافقين
رغم تازمتهم بموضوع قضيه محاكمه سليمان
شكرا جزيلا لكم
البحث في الشارع العراقي من عمان وواثق
الجابري الباحث السياسي من بغداد